and we are live the last word lord
cognito ibantas ty got travis fresh on
that thursday evening campfire back in
the saddle once again how are we doing
gentlemen let's start with the cheetah
himself mr ibantis how we doing sir
doing good um better after last week
just slowly kind of been recovering my
knee from my fall
i think it's honestly just been like
kind of a deep bone bruise where it's
just like it seems to be healing i seem
to be you know walking's a little bit
easy nothing's been too bad you know a
little bit of advil which you know
trying to not even do that nearly as
much it's just it's slowly getting
better but i know i hit it hard so it's
just like i think it's just have a
little bit of down time so between that
and then just kind of you know
managing puppy stuff i haven't streamed
in like a week i literally hadn't
touched like obs it's still been linked
up to youtube instead of twitch for like
the past week so
i've been doing that just kind of still
working on sealing up the house and
things like that for just like cracks
and window sills and stuff like that so
just kind of updating things but i will
say
kind of in my off time i have been
playing have a nice death i finally
started it up because after wrapping
tunic and
neon white and then eldest souls i did
actually finally go through and beat
that
nice powered through on that one
yes like once i got to a point where i
kind of got a rhythm going it was just
like boss boss boss boss done it was
just like kind of knocked him out i will
say have a nice death it's early access
right now so it's not done
um
hades set the bar and i was talking
about this with a friend of mine hey do
you set the bar for roguelikes like
through the roof like hades is so well
done between story animations the fact
that like when you actually go through
the loop there's a reason to go through
and go back again and like the intermix
stories in between and even the powers
you get are really good that's at the
bar insanely high like that's that's a
10 i mean that that for me would be like
a roguelike masterpiece that one
deserves that one
right now i think this one in early
access has potential to be around
probably about an eight for me
because i think it's just like it's
dripping in personality is the best way
i can kind of phrase that is because you
are death you are you know dude with the
scythe
and he's like fed up with work is the
best way i can describe he's he's
literally like it's already i mean the
death counters like times combating
burnout is literally how it's described
because the opening cinematic alone like
i have it recorded the opening cinematic
alone is you know it's death he's going
through he's doing a little swipe and
he's like okay now you're you know your
soul's going with me doing this then he
gets really tired because all of a
sudden it's like death death that's just
like more and more people so then he's
like okay i'm gonna hire all these goons
and then he's sitting at his desk but
it's like paperwork paperwork and then
he's just like stamping infinite
paperwork
and then he just gets to the point where
he's finally just like all right i'm
done so he just gets this like
burnt out like death guy and it's just
kind of and then you and then all your
people you kind of raised and then sent
them off to do their things they've been
you know going all over the place and
not really doing what they're supposed
to be doing so you're kind of reeling
the bosses back in that have been kind
of acting out of sorts but it's just
when you hit the pause button or when
you're going between levels the like
loading music is like officey elevator
music it's just like
perfectly it's
so like it the hades is too damn good to
like it's not that good but i will
definitely say like the combat is snappy
the dodge is quick um
the more of these weapons i've unlocked
there are bees that are they're bees
whatever i mean it's just one of the
things but it's like they're stupidly
powerful and then you get like a build
finally got one where i actually had a
little bit of life steal coming back and
i've actually had quite a bit of fun i
went through and finished a full run now
so i've made it you know through at
least one run
um
it just it's
the opening cinematic and then just the
little touches of
description sounds similar to death door
desk door is much more on the
kind of more serious side when you get
into the later part i would say because
like when you get to the latter part of
death door it's
there's some there's depth to like you
know the crow and the characters this is
a little more lighthearted the whole
time through like death is like pointing
with this like angry office manager face
type and that's
but just the way they kind of handle it
with good combat and fun variations i've
had so far i would definitely recommend
checking it out um no it's not gonna be
like hades i can't put it that high but
i will definitely say as it's early
access now and if they've got potential
to make it you know polish it up out a
little bit more
i think it's i mean
seven easy for me eight maybe depending
on kind of where it all ends up landing
but i was like i just enjoyed my time
because i just said personality i think
is the best way i can describe it so i'm
gonna go close my door so what about you
travis
i'm doing good man
i show off that zetablade
you see that you see those calves as he
walked away oh yeah
that was crazy yeah
they're not blessed with this right now
this is premium content that's good yeah
it's good yeah i'm feeling great i'm
feeling great it there's nothing quite
like getting uh getting done with a 150
hour rpg review but uh yeah man i've
been chilling i finished that i got my
roller drum preview out the door so um
okay check that out if you haven't seen
it roller drum is super fun it's
basically like
tony hawk pro skater but with guns it's
like uh
you know you you go around on
rollerblades and you do tricks uh in
fact doing tricks is the only way to
reload your weapons so your guns okay
you know you run you run out of ammo and
then it's like all right now i gotta go
do a sick kick flip um off of something
and then and then i'll you know get a
couple shots back and then go back into
it uh so that's pretty fun
um and uh yeah now i'm working on my
next review and my next preview
my next review i can't talk about but uh
it's
i think it's gonna be a return to form
for people who like my usual reviews
let's just put it that way
there's not enough ink to uh take these
down this is okay so here's my here's my
speculation on this one five or below
five or below
okay that's where you going
well that's what you're asking uh i'm
gonna guess yeah okay i don't know i
nailed the last one i will say because
we last yeah we should all mention that
yeah yeah it was like you're getting it
was well i mean
we've talked enough before show i can
usually feel you'd be like oh dude i
cannot
this game or
you won't say quite as much or however
you talk about it so it's like i had you
know a little context to go into it but
xenoblade chronicles if you haven't
watched the review please go watch it um
very good review but it got an eight and
i called it last week without knowing
anything and then tell the story of when
i said that
like how close were you to making your
decision
that's right yeah i think i had just
locked in the score of the day you
guessed that and you're like an eight
and then i just tried to like not have
any response in my face poker face
yeah i'm just going to be like
yeah inside i was screaming so thanks
for
validating my 150 hour journey um
i i had a lot of fun reviewing that game
it is a great game if you're into jrpgs
at all it's super daddy loves it i
thought it would be he reviewed it i
told him about duke
he just thought he's like 20 something
hours in he's all invested
nice cool he agrees with you though yeah
it's good it's a it's a great game it uh
it it has you know problems but i i
would recommend anybody who likes jrpg
should play it it's quite good
um if you don't like jrpgs you probably
won't like it because it is very jrpg in
certain spots but um yeah it just sort
of depends
um i like jrpgs generally speaking i
have problems with the genre as i do
with any genre but uh
generally speaking i like them um yeah
and i actually have also been playing a
lot of destiny
yes basically as soon as i was done with
xenoblade i needed some comfort food so
i came back
hopped into solstice and um
i'm like i'm almost there i'm almost
done with that activity and i think i'm
going to get the fire keeper actually oh
wow you're going for the title i'm just
as surprised as you already killed mine
oh okay okay okay i didn't have 150
hours so like yours is more impressive
but
it is
so where would you now that you've spent
a good amount of time if you're working
on the seal where where is this thing
coming in for your how's your comfort
food tasting how is how's this dish like
you know how's it coming in
you know if you have nothing better to
do and you're coming off of a 150 hour
review it's a it's a nice way to pass
the time
um
it's not my favorite event i mean it's
basically just driving you toward all
the stuff you've already done i do like
the changes they made to the european
aerial zone in general i think that the
traversal options and the fact that it's
a little faster and you're not running
around hunting for chests afterwards i
think
the more you do it it's one of those
things that after a while you're like i
don't need to chase the chests
again
but it's like but then on the other side
now it's just like and little i will say
this is one of the few things that's
just like loot vomit out of the little
fire
yeah and it's like it kind of feels like
uh outriders thing was like ball
yeah
i don't like the armor upgrade system i
think they should have kept that like it
was before it's it's needlessly
uh confusing it it adds more currencies
with yeah
the burning of the ash so that you can
reinforce your armor so that yeah it's
absurd but uh you know if it for me it's
just been
super long days and i get i sit down on
the couch and i have like 90 minutes
before i need to go to bed and i'm just
like yo i don't have time to get into
anything so i'm just going to sit down
and just quickly that's why
it's nice and uh
what are they gonna put dusty on the
switch that's my question
the switch couldn't handle it you
literally talked about that in your
review because i joked afterwards i
watched it i was like can you imagine
xenoblade 3
just on even like a ps
4 ps4 pro xbox one x like just like
1080p 60 just i mean warframe is running
on a switch
yeah warframe's running out of switch
what else is we're running on the switch
the witcher 3 okay here's the question
would you which or three runs at like
540p that's not a good example
um no destiny could run at 540p what's
wrong with that it's on switch it
doesn't have to run it no so here's the
question if you have to pick would you
rather see destiny work on the steam
deck first or on the switch first
switch
wow
let me hear this break it down
steam deck is
not my favorite console for a lot of
reasons
you are one of the rare ones for sure
jesus i have two of them man well i'm
not that i don't think i've been with
you switch wow
here's the thing i think if you play
online games the the um
steam deck is disappointing because
eighty percent of my games don't run on
the steam deck uh and the reason i will
say the games that i like don't run up
exactly
the games are most
if you like single player games and you
just want to go and replay all the the
pixel remasters of the old final fantasy
games like steam deck is awesome and you
can you can play a lot of the older
single-player games i think that's
really cool but
uh
the thing
one the screen is bad on the steam deck
it's like it's like actually bad the the
switch screen is better i mean you got
the oled
i have the oled yeah oh that's what yeah
i got the old okay yeah and the things
actually look better on the switch just
from a screen perspective even though
the games obviously don't perform as
well and then also because of the i was
talking about um i was talking about
this today on a nintendo voice chat with
uh uh john heinemann from uh from um
digital foundry he was on the show with
us
john lennon thank you
homie i love letterman
what is what is their channel
yeah there we go yeah yeah wait what was
he doing over there nintendo
what was he doing he reviewed xenoblade
chronicles 3 from a technical
perspective and actually what's funny is
that we had talked about it before we
realized we were going to be on the show
together so it was like oh that's
the show together that's cool
i love you so much
but um a lot of a lot of games that run
um on unreal 4 have uh
have frame rate problems and
it's it's especially bad on the the
steam deck and consoles don't have that
uh problem uh with unreal four
specifically and so a lot of games will
actually run frame wise better on the
switch even though they run in lower
fidelity but you don't need 4k on a
portable device you know you can run a
game at 540 and as long as the frame
rate's good like yeah the frame's okay
now it can go well so i i um i i i own
two steam decks i do not have a problem
with that console i think it's a great
console but uh i just
for my money i feel like the switch is
more accessible uh there's more of them
out there in the hands of people uh you
know just for all those reasons i would
rather see destiny expand a switch if i
had to choose well you're going to be
practical about it for like user base
size g
yeah
it'll be all logical and stuff i mean
yeah
to be honest with you yeah
um
either one would be great but it's crazy
that you can play destiny on your phone
and not on the switch or the steam deck
that's just weird to me that's what it
comes down to
yeah they got to get that whole thing
straightened out
yeah man i mean for me it's just been
kind of not sleeping it sounds like yep
yeah yeah let me ask you how you're
doing i forgot yeah
i'm exhausted
oh there's a lot going on a lot of stuff
good stuff though good planning good
travel stuff planned and good guesting
stuff but um yeah for like what's been
going on actually i was still in my kind
of destiny hiatus take a break
you know i got as dust falls finished
which i absolutely loved i loved that
game
yeah man i really enjoyed it i thought
like i came into that game thinking this
oh this is just a little you know little
niche indie darling game that only i'm
gonna like it was one of those love at
first i knew when i saw it even though
people had an issue it's gonna be one of
the games if you don't like the art
style you're not gonna get into this
game it doesn't matter what happens
right but if you by like chapter two
i was so like invested already with what
was going on and how it was presented
and it's just world-class voice acting
world-class acting story narrative and
the choices where really
kind of at the end of a chapter you see
all the different variants and
truly like oh the closest that i think
that's done that it's probably mass
effect when you i was like detroit
become human
of course detroit of course detroit of
course i'm never going to dispense right
but it's like what i like is generally
those type of games
you know
if you have all this choice then it kind
of condenses at the end
yeah you know i'm saying not saying it
doesn't do this at all but there are so
many variants and if people don't
survive and other things
that you have drastically different
experiences and i speak to a lot of
people have finished it and i'm like
what that happened and then the not only
that the choice the relationships and
then the multiplayer aspect of it takes
it to a whole now like i would love
to see like
trav and
miss trav play and then like argue over
decision and then one uses the override
over the other one it really changes
that that takes the telltale formula to
the next level then it has the twitch
integration so you can play with your uh
streaming community i might have to do
that e i'm like bro you i would love to
see you and missy boss is playing that
like it and it's some tough
gut-wrenching really well-written stuff
so i would highly advise check out as
dust falls got a chance to interview on
me so i've got a chance to interview
that dev um interior knight a little
small on studio i knew they had one i
was like this you guys got one and i
think the reason why they're able to do
all the choices stuff is because of the
art style i think if they had the
traditional
gameplay type thing i don't know if
they'd be able to do what they would do
so i got that
stupid rock in the rocker
played power wash simulator did you
i did it is it is actually really good
exactly it's like i i'm afraid to pick
it up because it's gonna be i've even
joked with like my discord and i was
just like i should because all the mcu
crazy announcements came out and i'm
like
i'm not as deep on the comics books like
king would probably like just school me
for like i would go to like king comic
book school or something like that but i
mean
i feel like because there are people in
my discord there's black wings and new
red there's a bunch of people who know
all that type of stuff i'm like i need
to just play power rush simulator and
then throw them into voice chat and then
just stream while we explain everything
that's going to happen over the next
three years because power wash seems
like that thing where you could watch
like a season and be like oh oh and
you've done both like
it's stupid i've heard i mean skill up
review like i think it's the what is it
the fact that it like it's tactile and
the dings happen and just like
it's it's the
it's a mental psychological incentive
right and then what it is you you like
you clean the van and it's like are you
power
what's got me mad is i'm playing on my
friend shout out to the citizens of
and they're like hardcore it's no bro
you got to change the nozzle you're
using the wrong nozzle right here we got
to get real deep with this exercise
you're like i am doing this to relax
like
you cannot be serious right you giving
me the meta of power wash simulator
right there that's what we're really
doing like
that's how deep it was they had to co-op
mode and then they getting into it you
could crouch get in the pro you got to
pull a soft straight almost and you got
to go shut off gotta go gotta go solo on
that one and just enjoy it
if you don't if you don't mind max and
play to the meta how are you going to
get to the top of that comp oh you're
checking my build are you going to
i'm going on from so you got that but i
will say this e this is the funny part
like like i said it's their incentive
stuff the dings and all that but what i
go for it almost feels like when you
clean something
the the cleaned version like the most
ray traced vibrant reflective you felt
like you did something you're like oh
man this looks great now
psychological psychological satisfaction
the video game is what pretty much they
finally nailed one of those
yeah shot the best if he put me on and
last then i got back to destiny finally
this week and yes it is done
i heard
has been conquered did you enjoy that
little dude talking the whole time he's
ridiculous right yeah absolutely
hilarious yes did it it was it was fun
it was fun because what i liked this was
a nice little spin with the platforming
part like i thought that was cool and it
was like one hit i felt like i was
playing an old arcade game i jump in the
pool he's talking then you got to move
and do these little obstacles and
foolishness look it was it was it was it
was hilarious and we got a little
extra context on sabbath doing which was
good and the witness which was good now
that weapon
i don't know about just yet
okay i will say
it it has specific uses like i actually
used it in val on what is it the totems
encounter is that the first one the main
one yeah yeah so like i'll just leave it
in my back pocket just mow down the
little guys and all of a sudden like a
champion spawns just one worm like times
20 gone
just deletes big guys if you stack them
up that's doing this
yeah so that's like it's not meant to be
because the reload's awful that i get
but it's like if you just have it
sitting in the chamber i think it's got
auto loading holster on it too but if
you go stack 20 and all of a sudden you
switch over it just deletes whatever is
in that zone
because it hits like a truck
that's what i've used it for but i
haven't used it for much else the fun
thing yeah i jumped in you know get my
solstice on throwing bonfires and
messing around
and i'm like yeah
i'm ready for the next season
i'm like yeah this is cool
you know
there are three more weeks left of the
season after this one
it's like it's
it's feeling like this is downtown we
got some down time yup they're downtown
for me
but anyway sounds like i said oh no
salad okay okay my dogs and i'm trying
not to oh you muted
i always have like my ear like slightly
off so i can hear
what's going on in the other room
between dogs barking is it playing or
what's going on because oh huskies play
rough they just do
they oh i mean
most people look at huskies and be like
you need to break that up i'm like
that's normal that's nothing so like
that's normal it's like
you just gotta make sure you don't hear
that like tone change then you're good
whatever yeah
no no it's high pitched usually if it
goes
oh yeah when it's a yellow bit too hard
or whatever yeah yep yeah
puppy ain't playing nice what's going on
no they do no they do it's just that
moments where you know he like enzo's
like 70 pounds and he's about 40. so
he's poking the bear sometimes and
sometimes the bear pokes back and he's
like oh [ __ ]
yeah well sometimes it's one of those
moments more but it's he's also
kind of one of those like
well husky who cried wolf his bad choice
of words but he's like every so often be
like he's just like okay wasn't that and
then i'll see him just like walking
around be like dude what happened
nothing so he's kind of a big chicken
sometimes so it's just like but it's
always just gonna
they can you know it's good to have them
play everything yeah
like the dad to see the kids like this
this is how i play like 90 of the time
it's one on one off so i can hear the
rest of the house usually and that's
just why
yeah no i was like i got over my ladder
issue installed a ceiling fan you know
our you i don't even know if you
remember the house like the living room
it's like a 13 14 foot ceiling yeah very
well i finally had to replace that
ceiling fan so that took
better part of one of my days but i
finally got that thing done it just
just finally was crapping out and it
just gets to the point where like
do i sorry i was gonna say i just love
how often you have stories that are
house maintenance yes yes
i love it
if you do is like assembling furniture
and climbing up ladders and like this
your wife just has you going to work man
she's like dead
thank you thank you
do a room edition when any either of you
own a house and unless you're just like
i'm going to pay someone to do
everything if you're not that guy which
these two probably are
oh yeah do i look like i've worked a day
in my life look how soft my hands are
look at these i remember i remember
meeting you yeah your hands were rather
soft oh damn
no
why are you gonna do it like that i was
joking i was leaning into it i actually
don't even remember so versus his butt
cheek they were extremely soft that's
true yeah i was like you got to be
careful with my reverberation across the
convention
but no it's like you can go like at some
point had to replace the first thing i
probably did in my house was a toilet
and it's like you look honestly there's
so many youtube videos it's like how
what does it cost like pay somebody two
or three hundred dollars to install a
toilet or is like
buy the toilet and it takes like an hour
and it's done and it's not even
difficult it's just like a little bit of
time and you're good so just it starts
with one thing and the next thing you're
like all right can i do this or can i
not and there are things i just i'm like
nope it's out of my room but there's
some things i do i'm for the home
improvement channel where he bought this
let's go
no no there there's some
old no i you watch the professional home
improvement people that is a whole
different ball of wax so
very very very very particularly
crowded space [ __ ] it's a crowded man
listen he got in the destiny he could
get over there i'm telling you man i
don't know i don't know you got to know
your know your strength who's datto over
there
mike in chat was like the rule is each
job requires a new tool and that's
kind of a yeah toilet wax ring whole lot
of youtube yep that's a toy
uh but yeah it's like you get to a point
you need to finally get an electric
drill or whatever and you're like oh i
use this thing like all the time now
it's like i never had it before you know
it's the best thing ever so it's just
like stupid things is you you own a
house that crap is just gonna happen
like that and finally you're like i
don't want to wait on you know a plumber
who's going to take a week it's like
just let me fix my toilet it's fine
respect respect
i uh i have to come out as a
as a fraud i actually uh what you do i i
do i do uh maintain my house my dad was
like my dad was a carpenter and i
i was forced to learn the tools of the
trade and
i i play a character on the show
sometimes i'm not actually
[Laughter]
my next preview is construction
simulator where and i'm going to heavily
reference the fact that i worked in
construction for like five summers
i can't i can't just pretend like i just
never well you had the hard hat and the
j you broke the suit protocol
there was a time there was a timeline
yeah with thai guy travis
wore nine suits nine ties and one no he
came out of the womb in a suit that's
just how that happened how did this
happen so i wore it i wore a suit um but
i replaced my slacks with jeans
so i had like darker jeans on okay
okay and depending on the job i would
wear a helmet or not my dad wasn't
really a helmet guy because he's a man's
man if you ever met him
like that guy does not follow safety
yeah he's definitely breaking safety
entire personality yeah so yeah the vest
oh you had the vessel the vest on i wore
a tool belt i know what all those tool
belts do yeah dude i i okay so what was
your you did five years like what was
your specialty were you like hanging
drywall doing roofing plumbing what were
you doing let's do a little bit of
everything i'm i'm good at framing uh i
i also did uh foundation like digging
and doing like
what about that sheetrock
sheetrock um
like drywall not oh i mean
yeah because it's like say a sheetrock
that's what i want
yeah
there's my dark secret is that i i
actually am pretty handy around the
house just you got pictures you got
pictures of that
i mean
you gotta dig in the crate i'll pull it
up all you gotta do is ask all you gotta
do is ask ask his girlfriend and be like
all right is he handy or not because
she's gonna tell you straight
she doesn't even know who i am like she
doesn't have that those photos uh no
those photos are probably on like a
motorola or razer you know in
2007 or something you know
home improvement random destiny pot yes
here's what happens when we don't have a
guest guys sorry yeah things happen um
some of you guys may have heard guess
that was supposed to be on we'll work on
rescheduling for the future things just
happened no big deal
um
but yeah all of the preamble out of the
way
big thing that happened today is a dwab
um
outside of solstice is still going on
or if you haven't done it yet you can
still grind for armor i mean obviously
artifice armor from master dungeons is
going to be your optimal but if you are
trying to make a certain stat build for
a certain situation
you can lean pretty heavily into a very
specific set of stats that you want it's
really up to you guys shout out to mri
gamer real quick with the super chat for
five dollars thank goodness bungie is
finally doing spm now i had don't have
to play with sweaty's like travis and we
will get to that because a large chunk
of this swab and it's a pretty lengthy
one is about matchmaking but the first
piece is about raid the date so coming
up in season 18 will be our second go at
bringing back a raid out of the destiny
content vault and this time it's going
to be reacted
to no surprise to me at least that there
i loved on twitter people like this i
saw you predicted this right yeah you
did predict it yeah i mean i've been
saying it for everyone i was like i saw
people like oh we're going to get to
know we're going to get to know on the
12 i'm like no we're not they're not
going to tell you until the 23rd it's
like don't get your hopes up they will
tell you the date they will tell you the
time they might tell you level and
challenge mode and they did are they
going to tell you what raid all that's
coming in the showcase and sure enough i
was dead on
um so the weird one and i wanted to ask
you guys thoughts on this one the raid
is on
friday
three days after the season launches
so i think vlog vlog we got that like 10
day window right we got longer on vog i
feel i think so and then of course with
the expansion they will do the 10 days
so you get a chance to do that one but
they have been on saturdays for a little
while so i wanted to get you guys
thought on the shift to friday
because some people a couple of people
hadn't cared some do
my personal opinion
backwards yeah yeah i was like i feel
like the saturday was just a more
inclusive day generally not for
everybody but generally a saturday would
be more inclusive i didn't know if you
guys
had any idea why you think they went
with freddie um yeah i agree i think
definitely a step back saturday's the
day today i'm to do it i mean you get
the most engagement and people work like
they're acting like people not working
like that okay so to me did correct me
if i'm wrong when is the when's the date
is the 26th right so
now we're looking twenty shout out real
quick hold on
uh shout out to scott schultz with the
fifty dollar super chat always love your
content thanks for the years of good
stuff thanks for watching my channel for
years cause yeah it's been going for a
bit so scott thank you very much lots of
love appreciate that one
um any of you guys who watch the show
watch you know travis's reviews or cogs
or any of my videos thank you guys for
the support as always um when you guys
go above and beyond like that it's kind
of humbling so thank you all for the
super chats and just being here for any
of you guys in chat but damn thank you
good
my guess i guess with the date change is
that it's better for their team it's not
about the players i think it's probably
their team doesn't like working on
saturdays and probably launching a raid
requires a lot of coordination and
working on the weekend and that's
probably what it came down to is my
guess
they say nobody wants to work saturdays
right
yeah it's so weird though uh i think
also too we gotta factor in
that showcase
because that showcase is the 23rd
right
uh yeah it's tuesday the 23rd when the
season goes live yeah
that that's my i think
like like travis said this is aligning
with his thinking with the team because
they're gonna have to present they got a
big splash they want to make in
conjunction probably with the season and
then this raid acts the extra layer to
it so it's probably just too much with
the alignment and maybe they just said
okay you know what we have to drop a
friday but i'm curious now
if it's a specific rate if if a specific
raid has any
factor in doubt it does honestly i feel
like before that they've said that the
raid
the vaulted raids are not going to come
back with any tie into story
right i mean if this is like hey this is
steven we get wrath of the machine
i feel like that would be a massive
coincidence but i still don't even think
they would tie the raid into the story
right
over i'm just but but it can't be ceva
right because we know the next expansion
is witness
i mean it's lightful so doesn't mean we
don't have some connection to
that would be crazy if they're like
steve is back well i mean who's the
the war mind
yeah like rasputin somehow like
harnesses the technology like i mean
there have been jokes like that could be
an interesting thing that you could ever
do but i still don't think there's going
to be a story tying if there's any civil
related stuff it's still going to be
separate would be the idea i was going
to respect the team i do think it's a
mistake to to not to not do a raid on a
saturday though like i they had the nice
guys they've done them for a while like
it's been that way for a little while i
feel like because vogue was
forgiven because it's uh it's a
re-release like you know it's to me i
maybe maybe this is just my perspective
but i don't think it's that sacred
because it's uh
it's a raid we've already played you
know it's just good
people what that that that that that
title and the little you know what i'm
hardcore dudes you know how they get
those people will take a day off you
know what i mean
most people apparently um
hippie uh well i think her name is
lyanna is that right uh confirmed on
twitter that if something is as broken
as val
much easier for them to have all hands
on deck on a friday so for them to have
a response to
possible needed changes or hot fixes or
something along those lines they would
have more staff on
i mean that's one of those where you
kind of get
there's always i mean i've heard you
talk about it probably in everywhere
you've had podcasts is the idea of
crunch
working your overtime in certain
situations is kind of part of the job
sometimes and it's just like
this is your live service
is it too much to ask for a saturday
because
i mean you went from like five thousand
and three thousand to like thirty
thousand people being involved in val of
the disciples one of the biggest ones i
think they had done between the saturday
inclusion and ten days and things of
that nature so
i don't know for me i get the idea of
staffing to a point i know they're
trying to respect their staff and i know
the showcase is going to be kind of a
big deal
but as big as they tend to promote raid
races themselves
it does feel like having more inclusion
in it would probably be beneficial for
them because
you just have more people going for it
and the other thing also with this is
it's friday it's you literally have 72
hours to
now do your story quest which probably
isn't gonna take that long but then it's
like how now it's just even shorter time
frame to power through the artifact and
get your mods that you may want that far
tier on people are going to be stacking
bounties this time because you only have
three days instead of 10. now granted
the reason it's probably not 10 is
because of labor day i saw somebody else
mention that in chat
so labor day is probably an issue but
now it's
even shorter so
yeah i don't know i feel like it's i
feel like it's not going to come off a
great i think the bigger tell would be
when lightfalls raid launches if they do
that on a friday then we'll know the
saturday experiment didn't hold but yeah
and to me it's very strange because they
were boasting about how much engagement
numbers they had when they went to
saturday remember when deep stone creek
this was the most we've ever seen and
this is like so they've shown that
they've had great numbers with it look
i'll respect the team if they if you
what what's a homegirl i forget you know
lyanna right if she said that of course
i'm gonna believe what leonard said i'm
not gonna go against it it is just
strange so i i wonder if
like i said with the um
the gamescom on that gamescom but with
the lightfall reveal and everything just
being too close to proximity that makes
sense for the team but i'm curious after
that also is this going to be a friday
kids because i don't know if i like
fridays moving forward again that's like
the old days i want to get back to the
saturdays so let's see
uh
let's see part of the feedback or part
of the challenge of a game like this is
that we have two very different
communities there are and will be
challenges oh that's probably svm i was
trying to find the part where i was
talking about
rage okay i'll see if i can find it for
you guys
um
oh hold on what's the middle ground on
making the raid a weak day that's more
drought people work one of them because
we also work monday through friday and
remember how broken valve was when it
dropped this way something like that
happens we have all hands on deck
without burning out our teams
make sense there you have it it's a
practical reason but i still think it's
worse i agree with a player
yeah i mean
yeah i was like that's kind of things
not everybody works monday through
friday but a lot of them do yes they do
and they would have more hands on deck
to fix things but also
i don't know we'll see how it plays out
see how feedback is
that was
at least makes sense now i have some
context as to the reason
node is going to be perfect but i guess
for them if it helps make it smoother
and so be it
uh the other piece is all about
matchmaking
so they kind of do a tldr and then we'll
kind of break things into pieces
um
starting in season 18 we will be
introducing some changes in how we play
matchmaking in crucible this will be the
first generation that is part of a
larger plane going through season 19 our
world systems teams are leading the
charge on this transition and here with
a massive info dump basically
uh so the tldr is we're striving towards
a goal that all players including new
lights can enter the crucible and
regularly get matches where they can
feel competitive and have a reasonable
chance of winning
competing
making fair matches using skill based
matchmaking is going to be important to
help meet that goal we are starting by
implementing loose skill based
matchmaking to control playlists
at the start of season eight or to the
control playlist i'm sorry at the start
of season 18. loose sbmm has a wider
starting skill similarity than survival
so it should result in matchmaking with
a wider variety of players
while also eliminating some of the
frustration things kind of
when i was actually playing i think true
like true vanguard when we were playing
the one thing i liked kind of the way he
phrased it was just outliers like a one
should not play with a 10. like three
through ten one through seven i can kind
of see a pretty big range but a one in
ten shouldn't be in the same match
so in theory most of the people who have
schooled me in the pvp segment i have i
shouldn't be playing against them as the
idea
uh expect loose sbmm to expand to other
playlists in future seasons as we tune
what we consider a high quality match by
gathering real data and feedback from
you we are not complaining we are not
planning to add it to every match made
crucible playlist we will continue
tuning until we are in a good good place
we report tuning
we'll report tuning updates regularly
we'll be implementing a
form of fire team size preferred
matchmaking in season 19.
that'll be a big piece as well
um
so
high points they go in details of
connection quality and creating high
quality matches
match fairness and matchmaking speed so
they say there are two types of
connections that are important
connection to the game server connection
all other players
generally bad connection to other
players have a larger feedback on or
effect on crucible basically because
most of destiny is pv or player to
player matchmaking
lower quality matches result in jerky
movements we get that one match fairness
ideally all players on a match have
reasonable chance to win and matchmaking
speed
you know how long it takes you to find a
match
um so just kind of in an overall sense
how does some of this stuff come across
to you and kind of the tldr travis i
know gotta go to you first
where do you in even just the tldr sense
of this come across in reading is this
sound like something that might have
some potential do you like it where do
you love it
yes this needs to happen i mean uh
the current model of having well
depending on what you think is actually
true it's either the wild west which is
a terrible way to
create uh
matchmaking i mean it's not really
matchmaking if you're just grabbing six
random people and then
for 12 random people and then doing
snake draft that's that's uh
basically just uh
a grab bag methodology which some people
suspect is a thing
um
i also kind of think that that's how it
works i think it i think it just has
some sort of like very vague grouping
and then it just grabs people and then
does like a snake draft
other people
suspect that it works by
grabbing people with higher skill and of
lower skill and trying to like mix them
all together
that's terrible because it means that
the
people who aren't as good have basically
no impact on the match they have no
control over whether they can help them
win or even or you know they're i mean
sure they will help them lose but
they can't really have any any influence
in the match unfortunately and so
i get why people are wary of skill-based
matchmaking
part of it is that streamers that
are uh have a vested interest in
skill-based matchmaking not existing
have convinced other people that
skill-based matchmaking is bad uh even
though it would help them most more than
anyone else um
but uh the other part is that you know
some games have done it poorly including
destiny in the past and when it's poorly
implemented it can be a painful
experience but
you know the headline should be
skill-based matchmaking has to exist if
you want matches to not feel completely
hit or miss
uh and and not fair right and so
uh
their intention is noble
i think it needs to happen if you want
to have a competitive
uh a competitive multiplayer in your
game
whether or not they're choosing the
right way to implement it remains to be
seen but i'm happy that they are
actually
thinking about it and doing something to
go in this direction because it needs to
happen i mean
it just it just needs to it the the
current the current uh situation is
not uh good
i don't think anybody thinks that
matches feel
amazing right now except for probably
streamers who absolutely benefit from a
lack of skill based matchmaking but uh
yeah dude we need something like this
because i'm happy that they're doing
that
no i'm sorry i finished the travis
you'll say you're happy to go to
well i'm just happy i'm happy that
they're they're tackling it that's good
yeah i mean
say something funny
i feel like look got
the last word on the back a little bit
i feel like there's one show that has
been fighting this fight for a long time
even when there's no pvp topics we
mentioned pvp you know what i'm saying
so
of course the community is on it of
course but
where's the credit we've been on it man
we've been on it about you know the
neglect so this was a refreshing swab
and i know we got more to read but from
so far this is refreshing because what i
like i like when you get to tell me from
a pvp standpoint your mindset that's the
thing i always feel is disconnect we
don't know what they're doing they just
oh we made some changes in the back but
what's the mindset what's the thought
process now we're seeing okay stuff we
probably assumed right but it's good to
see it right now okay part of this is
matchmaking time part of this is
connection based part of this okay we
want to implement skill based
matchmaking on some level in this one
place playlist and here's why right and
that's how you start bridging the gap
from a group that is severely neglected
right that doesn't feel they get the
same attention me and travis talk about
the daddy example like they don't feel
like the other kids like we just don't
so when i see this i'm like that's what
i want to see now i know a lot of pve
guys in the chat they already read the
chat top this week was oh i stopped
reading after paragraph well but this is
how we feel
when the twelves are dominated by pve
content and rightfully so it's great
content but overall look this is a great
start
what i like is the measured approach not
heavy-handed so far you know what i'm
saying
thought in one playlist let's see how it
goes it looks like they're going to take
feedback the thing that's that's key for
me though is
all this is great
but the fire team stuff to me adds
another wrinkle i know we're going to
talk more about it because we know how
it is when you match you already with
your guys and your guys are all of
variance think about you playing banner
or something sometimes you have those
parties where you got varying skill
levels like you know i'm like the third
you know i'm number five right and i got
like two killers with me and then we got
one guys like hey i'm just here for the
fun and you know you don't really pay
pvp right let's be honest we got that
guy so that's how i want to see
how they tackle that because i'm not
saying there's an easy answer for any of
this but i i want to see how they tackle
it
that's not really matchmaking though cog
if you're in a party full of people and
they have varying skill sets
you've already decided to override the
matchmaking mechanic in the game and at
that point you probably should go up
against other people who have made that
decision it's a lot harder of an
algorithm but you basically are
operating outside of matchmaking
matchmaking what i'm concerned with is
like the average player who is
just hopping into a queue which i think
this group right here isn't that how
most of us
play
pvp well most of us can't know
you get into it i gotta imagine that's
the way most people experience pvp
and i'm in agreement that's why the
reason why i mention it is because of
the key bullet point
we will be implementing a form of fire
team size preferred matchmaking the fact
that they were cognizant of that to me
was very telling i'm like okay you're
even thinking about that so now i'm
getting excited you like again it's
early but yeah i got a lot more to say
we got more a lot more to read but i'm
just curious where you're at with the
initial opening statements
uh i mean generally i'm the same way
it's like
i don't know it's one of those things
i've i've heard different sides of the
argument that's why i do want to pull
together a few different pvp minds and
have them on the podcast to talk about
this because
some people are
too just yeah no it's like i mean
connection skill somewhere in between i
mean some people like drewski i think is
one to a point he's like hey whatever
helps the population of the playlist
he's kind of on board for it just kind
of helping it grow and things of that
nature um
and shout out real quick to xentos new
channel member thank you very much
um
but that's kind of thing it's like
as travis is saying it's like the high
skilled people have the issue that skill
based matchmaking is going to put them
into
basically matches where
they don't get to let off the gas
and to a point i understand that
statement because if you're not and
especially as this game leans very
heavily into the matter scott with the
super chat and the membership thank you
um
the game leans heavily into the mud at
meta and then at this point if you take
high skilled people or
people who are just like up at that
level you get people at a point where if
they go to
you know say somebody like an ascendant
nomad wants to go test all the pulse
rifles he's going to go into pvp and if
he's not using the elite stuff in
something that's skill based it makes it
very difficult for him to to experiment
with something that even has like off
perks it was like i get that discussion
but
that small collection of people
sometimes does have to remember the
other 80 percent doesn't like getting
crapped on
when
you know you have that one person who
goes into a match and you'll see some
statistics in here where it's like the
kill differential is like 20 to 29 or 30
to 39 if somebody has 11 and somebody
else has 50 person 11 is having a much
worse day than the person at 50 who
might now have to go fight it out for
like everybody being around that 25 to
30 range so
i've always been around the idea of like
skill-based matchmaking does need to
exist somewhat
and i think
again i think the the way they're
phrasing this the loose sbmm
feels like a decent way to start now
there are a couple statements in here
that i do have some questions about and
we'll get to those but the idea of loose
sbm mmm as a place to start i think
helps with those outliers because if you
take a skill pool of one to ten just
basic numbers a one should never be in a
match with a ten
period but then on the other side the
ten shouldn't have to be paired with a
bunch of ones to try and go against like
fives and sixes and then most of you
guys are still gonna lose because the
one can't carry an entire team
so it's like those are the type of
things that kind of need to be addressed
and it seems like they're
mentioning both the party size
the black the snake matchmaking we'll
have to see if that like how that kind
of gets handled but also the skill
should help you know narrow down that
pool so even if you do a snake it's a
better pool to do that within yeah
this snake uh a snake draft only really
works if there are people of
somewhat in the same sphere of skill
with one another because otherwise it's
just
it's too much of a crap shoot
yeah gap is really big
so they say throughout the 12 we'll be
using the term skill and they basically
refer to a plus two minus one thousand
skill bell curve
um to no surprise there's a bell curve
in there
um and they say internal skills a
combination of stats made up on kills
deaths captures round wins revives dunks
et cetera
that rank you against other players in a
match they also see there's other things
um
there's also a confidence rating the
more games the system has seen you in
recently then the more confident the
skill adjustment is so like if you
played a whole lot like three seasons
ago it's not going to be quite as like
really hardcore on that one versus if
you're a very active player i want my
confidence that i like that
well okay this will get to one of the
lines that i have an issue with in a
second
in addition
to the stats mentioned above skill
encompasses all sorts of things your
reaction times agility how you approach
i mean that's just ask any of the pvp
like nomad or physics or any of the
people that we've had on there and it's
like you know the 80 20 rule how do you
play how much air mobility do you take
into account like are you building into
airborne effectiveness so you can
be that you know top five percent that
actually uses the verticality in the
game that's a whole different piece that
they can't really measure as much but
that's part of the performance
one of the first lines that i read that
i didn't love though is you won't ever
see a skill value in game
now
they mention something like elo that's
something that's done by like destiny
tracker and stuff and that's not what
they use specifically for skill
but that line right there makes me worry
about what we've talked about
ever seeing a ranked playlist actually
exist because you see a number
and if they don't ever want to
now maybe that skill value specifically
about kills deaths that behind the ones
we won't see and maybe the ranking we
will but that just has me worried that
they still don't ever want to attach a
number to you because they're afraid to
number you does that make sense i know
that sounds
generic i don't
i don't read that as them not wanting to
implement a interior-based ranked system
okay good because that that does not
speak to your skill all it speaks to is
how high you've managed to climb in the
season it's
it's it it's very different from like
your season level being above your
character's head versus it giving you
like some sort of number for what your
stats are in pvp yeah you're a 3.78
you're like i don't know what that means
exactly yeah and and to give a little
context to this just because i have
talked to lots of bungee employees about
this like you know back back in the
before times before coveto and i would
go to the bungee offices pretty
frequently
i used to hear people ask them about
elo they would they would ask them about
the uh
the the skill rank system and
bungee employees honestly would
sometimes be a little hostile to people
who brought that up they would just
immediately like throw it away and be
like we don't look at that we do not we
don't consider that a real stat blah
blah blah because it was a fan created
stat right and obviously there's some
math behind it it's a it's a real thing
but it uh the way that they think about
it is that it's not part of their game
design and anytime somebody would ask
them about it they would just say like
get out of here with that
and these were people who were
representing the pvp team pvp leadership
and sandbox that sort of thing so i
think what they're trying to say with
that statement is that their position
has not changed on that that they do not
consider the uh
uh you know that that stat to have any
merit and that they don't uh plan on
incorporating it with their
game or their game design and i think
that's the right call
i think you you let people decide their
own
skill level season to season and and you
know let them move up and down that
ladder but that doesn't mean you have to
attach
a
you know a ranked level uh or a ranked
grade on 1-10 or anything like that and
i actually think that something like
that
would kind of
suck
you know i
somebody in the comment section said oh
i really missed the 50 uh skill
50 levels from the halo 2 competitive
days
i do too like part of me feels that but
also
competitive online gaming has evolved so
much since that point and i don't think
that we have to go back to that i think
there's better ways to do it that are uh
more practical and less uh
i don't know how to describe it it's
more just that
i need to write this down at some point
i'm going to at some point i'm going to
write a an op-ed uh for fry jan on this
uh but yeah it it
i think i think that they're looking at
it more holistically on like
how do we use skill-based matchmaking to
make crucible matches feel better
without making it a a pecking order yeah
absolutely that makes sense yeah so that
your whatever they do come up with a
skill value from all of their statistics
we don't need to see that but that
doesn't mean we're not going to get a
ladder ranking system they can be
mutually exclusive right that's what
sounds okay
yeah and they said uh while we're
currently only using it to try and get
fair matches in survival elimination
they track it for all modes including
gambit and it gives us a reasonable
place to start up for
rift or zone control things of that
nature um for example remember it's a
bell curve the middle is basically zero
i see a lot of people sit at about a
hundred um
but you go all the way up to a thousand
or minus one thousand and the way they
describe it is if someone is 200 skill
above you you can definitely tell they
are better than you and they will win 75
percent of the engagements the opposite
is true of someone 200 below
if you get up to about a 400 difference
in skill uh the better players are going
to win about 90 percent of the time and
if you get up to about 600 they're
basically going to win every time if
you're the 600 skill above so that's the
range you're looking at so if you're a
200 going against an 800
you probably don't have much of a shot
from what they see in general yeah you
might win every blue moon or get like a
lucky snipe or something but most of the
time yeah you're probably going to lose
that but if you're close it
engagement should get fair the closer
you get to the same skill
so the problem space as we get started
looking at competitive landscape we
noted a few things outside of survival
and elimination the ability to influence
whether your team wins or loses is
usually out of your personal control if
you are average skill or below half of
the population do you guys think that's
a reasonable statement do you feel if
you average jump into a crystal match
you don't have a lot of control over the
outcome
i'm gonna say i'll just be for myself
and myself
i agree with that i feel like
my experiences with destiny pvp lately
and i'm not no god to your person but
when i'm playing for example in the
let's say the trials playlist and i'm
doing freelance
and i feel like i'm carrying
and like i'm just like damn like
who am i matched with like i just feel
like i don't i don't have anyone
comparable and it's not a good sign to
me like i don't feel like like you know
it's just it doesn't matter like it's
like
i could be playing i feel good as as a
skill that i'm okay i'm doing what i can
but i'm like i look at the outcome i'm
like and i know i'm like damn we're not
it doesn't matter we're not going to win
this match there's no way no how based
on not to be disrespectful who i match
with and i feel like when i play
i don't get
i hate to say the guys that i feel like
okay that guy's good like i get it it
becomes rare like i look as soon as the
bad start will load in i look at the
three and what i usually do is i start
to watch movement right and i look at
who who got picked first who's that and
then sometimes i'm like okay this guy's
getting picked a lot i'm gonna go trail
him and help him out you know what i
mean so that he i could try to keep him
alive because at least baby we got this
one guy seems semi-decent right
my my experiments have been like damn
like i just feel like i'm not really
playing with anyone
close to my skill level i'm not that
good
so what's going on with matchmaking so
yeah i do feel a lot at times that i
don't get
you know i don't feel like what i did is
really going to change this outcome of
this
no i mean i kind of get that point like
i've you know we joke about me lies like
i feel like i'm probably like right
around that like 1.0 1.1 like i do okay
and depending on the match sometimes i
get crapped all over and then sometimes
but it's the point where i feel like if
i'm leading our side
i feel like we're probably going to lose
now if i'm sitting at like i'm feeling
good i'm sitting at like three and
there's two other gods on my team then
we probably crapped on the other team
but if i'm leading our team that's
probably gonna be a loss it and i don't
even know if that's 100 accurate but
that somehow feels like
if i'm the top player on our team i feel
like we are not destined to do great
unless like it's like that one miracle
lobby and you're like somehow we pulled
like but that does not happen often
that's like so rare
and i'm like yo
i befriend this guy right now
and i'll be like after like yo yo what
you doing you want to get run and i got
a couple of playstation guys we rocked
out because other than that it's so far
between again it's it's antidote because
it's only my experience but that's how i
feel probably the last
four to five three you know two to three
seasons yeah like that's how i feel like
actually in the trials game mode
specifically well i'm curious about
about you know trav too how he feels
about that in general with his
experience
yeah my experience is more like i just
never the biggest problem to destiny's
pvp
uh which there are a lot of problems
there's support there's the still using
peer-to-peer servers i mean let's be
honest the destiny's got a lot of
problems
um
but
to me the biggest the biggest the
biggest problem that they're facing is
matches never consistently feel good
either i'm on a team or i'm just
destroying i'm just destroying the other
team and it's like not even fun or i'm
on the other end of it where i'm doing
okay but the rest of my team is
struggling and i'm just watching us just
just get destroyed in the scoreboard and
there's no chance for me to win um and
those are two hells
really because i don't want to pub stomp
people that's not why i play pvp if i
wanted to do that i would go and you
know log on to halo infinite and play
against bots right you can get the same
level of satisfaction just killing you
know
really really poorly programmed bots if
you want to do that
but and i but i also don't want to feel
like uh matches are unwinnable and that
has nothing to do with my skill level
because that who who here hasn't played
in a match where they felt like they
could beat every single person on the
enemy team in a 1v1 but they're losing
the match terribly because their team
just can't keep it together and that's
also a terrible experience and i would
just like it to be more consistent and
the only way you do that is you narrow
the pool to try to actually match people
based on their relative skill levels and
make matches fair and then the people
always say like oh travis you want you
know every every match to be like a
sweat fest
well yeah some of them
certainly at the level that i'm playing
at well i'm not going to say like right
now i'm a god i've i've played less
destiny this year than i ever have and
just in general my skill has declined
over the years and
anyway but you know at the level that
i'm playing at
it probably a lot of the matches would
be sweaty with skill-based matchmaking
but that's also what i want i want to
feel like i'm getting better and that
each match is a close call and that you
know it's exciting and
i'm actually sharpening my skills and if
you're at the bottom of the pool
you you'll have a very different
experience but at least you're going to
be playing with people in your bracket
and that's how you get better you're
never going to get better playing
against people who are way better than
you or way worse than you it's just not
not a good way to play the game so uh i
i just think
people say that skill-based matchmaking
is going to ruin things and i'm going to
say first of all there's nothing to ruin
the experience is very bad it's not like
that you know we can implement
skill-based matchmaking and matches
would somehow be even more inconsistent
that's not really on the table i think
and what what do you want from
competitive
do you want it to be a grab bag of
craziness or do you want it to be you
want to feel like a competitive match
yeah like bro i'm with you because it's
like again i play trial's fairly
consistent and
if to me it's a better alternative when
it's like you know three two all right
there we messed up that one next round
okay
it just feels better you know say i
don't consider that oh my god super
sweaty and if people consider that super
sweaty
the alternative of getting
wiped out 5-0
for like the majority of your day
bro you know what i'm saying and like
don't get me wrong and then to the point
the opposite okay let's say you are
stomping you you
you get you do your stop you get your
joint and you out right you you really
you don't say like it so to be at least
when there's a little push pull right
it's it's more of an excitement factor
and then also people are trying to get
better like i i prefer it you know so i
don't i don't see why well i have my
theories you know i said but you know
why there's such an opposition to it you
know i'm saying because at the end of
the day it's like you want to improve
you want to get better so yeah i'm with
all of this that that's where i'm at i
and i like that they're going to at
least do it in one mode that that that
to be at least is a good start let's
let's see how it looks first before we
throw stones and tomatoes at the screen
and then let it play out let them tweak
yeah also just what have you got to lose
that's what i have to say
does anyone feel like their current
matchmaking is good
even people who are again even people
who are against skill-based matchmaking
do they think matchmaking and destiny
right
if it ain't freelance i ain't playing
that's where i'm at right now i don't
know about chewie but trial i gotta keep
going
balance though
true you still have some unbalanced
weirdness but it's like it's so i'd
rather deal with that hell
than the wild wild west and i oh my and
i'm like oh i'm never paired with anyone
decent
and it's like oh here come the two stack
here come to three stack and i'm just
like
today's gonna suck and i was like i'm
logging off i did what i had to do
but where are you at with that as far as
like
just to feel and everything no i mean
i'm in the same boat um trying to like
reach out to shadow because he jumped in
um because he's in here the debate
against uh once again
yeah i was like but i was like i know
there are people and that's always again
that's why i want to get that like
collaboration of like different minds to
see but for me and again personally i'm
average
so it's like for me and that average
player it does feel like there are times
where it's like oh i feel like i'm
hitting the shots and then there's other
times where i feel like you know i'm
just getting like
taken out left and right or and it just
kind of depends and you feel some of the
you feel it's a little all over the
place and i think travis said it well
it's like the inconsistency
doesn't allow you to feel
doesn't allow you to really as you said
either hone your craft or feel like
was it luck or were they good or were
they bad or was i good it's like there's
just too many questions to really know
and register in your mind and they kind
of say something at one point that
actually gets to that
i'll keep going uh they said this can
feel bad as the match outcome feels
essentially random and you don't feel
motivated to try and win that's
literally it i mean outside of rewards
we've talked about crucible awards we
know like that may need some work at
some point but if you don't know if
you're doing good or bad in the first
place how do you literally register it's
like yeah i got a kill but when you look
back and be like cool i got that one but
then the next match you just completely
are on the other side like you were in
the like stranger things in the next
match here in the upside down
what like what caused that to you and
it's just and it does feel like it is so
all over the place i think as you guys
said just the lack of consistency the
randomness it doesn't feel like there's
there's not like a steady
mountain that you can climb it feels
like you're going through peaks and
valleys all the time there's not a lot
that you can wrap your head around to
know
did i excel there why did i get crapped
on this one went well oh my god i walked
around the corner into five team shots
like those definitely happened yeah i
just want to add on and and this is
where they talk about the problems
percentage right after is my biggest
issue right because it literally affects
what i want right which is better
rewards in the crucible and they
literally say this is contributing to
the emphasizing
but listen to that statement that that
that has contributed against it again
the whole thing
yeah this could feel bad as the batch
outcome feels essentially random and you
don't feel motivated to try to win this
has contributed to us
de-emphasizing winning as a requirement
to gain rewards in the crucible that is
a damning statement like and i hate that
little lines that hurt when i was just
like
isn't that clear though that's why they
always give you objectives that are like
you can do this even if you suck at the
game and
and then that that also
uh precipitates it because then it then
it makes it
then people are in matches trying to
accomplish side objectives and not even
worrying about complete uh winning the
match and that that's another pet peeve
of mine is when you enter match and it's
clear that you're the team you're
playing with isn't even trying to win
they're just trying to do something else
they're trying to like meme their way
through the match it's crazy oh that
exotic quest they got from the bad pass
that forced them to get the catalyst to
do some type of kills in pvp and then
they out you see everybody with the same
gun doing the same
that'd be funny to me too oh my god but
i'm with you i'm with you but that
statement i was like wow it was like
bold clear as day
with what they do and i'm like okay
interesting oh oh we got some info
we got it defended let's go a new
challenge okay video is gonna look weird
for a second but
shadow is here i don't know if you can
see us or not
uh sorry for messing up your video
no like i don't care about the video
this is like i mean i've literally
wanted to get multiple people in here
like physics you
cool guy a nomad like if i could get
like a whole bunch of heads together but
i know even on twitter there were some
thoughts about spmm so
as you are
i think for
not having sbmm if i i probably said
that poorly but okay let me just hear
your side of this whole thing since
you're jumping in
yeah so i i actually tweeted out that uh
skill-based matchmaking stands for super
bad matchmaking
instead of skill-based matchmaking um i
mean
to be clear i mean i'm talking
exclusively about control in in that
tweet and because i mean that's kind of
the topic of the 12 they're only
changing it in control at this time so
um
my take on it is that just that like 6v6
is supposed to be the casual playlist
the social playlist the playlist you
play with your friends um the playlist
where you can just hang out and relax
and use off meta stuff or sweat it out
if you want i don't care um but
i i think that um
if people want a skill based matchmaking
experience they should just go play one
of the playlists that has skill based
matchmaking because there are playlists
that already have it
and you know
having playlists without it like control
is right now i feel like that's that's
kind of an essential part of many
people's pvp experience
okay so let me ask you this just from a
very average player's point of view
i am an average player i go into a match
and
i have a roller coaster of an experience
depending on the match sometimes i win
sometimes i lose but i don't do well
do you feel okay so there's an example
if you say
so do you think any skill based
matchmaking should be in control at all
do you think there should be zero loose
tight where do you feel spm should be in
control just for an example
none personally personally i'd have none
in the control playlist but i mean if
you wanna if you wanna fudge it you know
i might i might be convinced to say like
you know if you wanna if you wanna not
match day one players with the people
who've been you know super sweats you
know like that's that's fine yeah i mean
if if you want to not match me with
people who literally installed the game
today that's fine but
it's really it's a slippery slope
because once you start doing that then
you just keep escalating and eventually
it's like oh you only match people who
are like almost as good as you and then
it's like oh great so now i have to wait
nine minutes from iq time and it's gonna
match me against people who are the same
as me so that's that's a pretty awful
experience
no so that's fair and that's one thing
they do get to is
connection matching
times if you could take connection
matching times out of the equation which
i know is obviously an impossible thing
to do realistically but if connection
matching times weren't a thing
say take a scale of one to ten
and i know you're saying like the output
so right now you're saying a one
shouldn't match a ten but do you think a
two should match a ten or where do you
feel that range is connection times out
of it again just the true
matchmaking of a general pool
where do you feel is a reasonable range
that say put yourself as a 10 how low do
you think should be facing against you
um
i don't know it's a tough question i i
think um
like i said i personally i would just
have it be completely open and have no
skill based matchmaking but if i had to
have skill based matchmaking i don't
think i would go higher than like a two
okay just one all right well no no
no go ahead yeah no
i gotta get i gotta get travis in here
in a second but coggy got something
first
crabs again i just got two questions i
want to make sure i'm clear with shadows
right so basically from what i hear your
your mindset is
sixes is a casual mode and sixes is
something that you want to kind of
experiment trying different things and
because of sixes
you don't want skill-based matchmaking
in that mode are you against skill-based
matchmaking in the other bones you want
skill my question is do you a skill
based matchbook completely removed from
destiny in its entirety it's my question
no i do not i mean i think i think there
are plenty of modes where it makes sense
or could make sense um like right now
the way that survival is you know that's
totally fine if people want to play
against people who are in their skill
level sure go play a mode that has it in
that's i mean that's what i said
originally um
yeah so i i just think that there needs
to be like at least a healthy amount of
playlists that don't have skill-based
matchmaking um and then if they're also
there there can also be ones that do
have it that's that's perfectly fine so
basically it's sixes if i if i'm clear
right
yeah it's that okay i see where you go
okay all right let me let it track i
just wanted to clarify so i just wanted
to know if he did not want skill
baseball i just i just had to do it but
travis i know you you troubled at the
bit you got stuff in your yeah no he's
still wrong um
i was surprised you were free i was like
yeah get on here if you can oh
yeah appreciate the consistency he was
wrong last time on the show too so
um
travis's views do not view are not all
the views of the last word podcast
the the problem with uh the problem with
that that theory that there should be
certain playlists with no skill based
matchmaking
is the very things that you state as
being problems uh for implementing
skill-based matchmaking like lower play
counts and long wait times uh those
exist because we don't have skill-based
matchmaking because people who who jump
into playlists that are ali oxen free
those are not uh
playlists that that people want to be a
part of especially when they're learning
the game or the new players or their low
skill it doesn't give them a chance to
develop schools and they uh they they
drop off the mode they stop playing it
and then that drops the player
population and so if you have absolutely
no protection for players the only
people it benefits are people like you
they're people who are at the top of the
playlist who are either going to get
maybe a sweaty match sometimes but most
of the time they're going to be able to
just have fun and experiment with the
meta but the people that never get to
experiment with the meta are the people
who need to experiment with it the most
the people who are at the lower end who
have no protections whatsoever and so
you know it's like when you're building
a society you got to prevent protect
your most vulnerable citizens to a
certain extent you can't just lais a
fair uh you know
your
pvp economy and so i i think that i get
what you're saying not every mode needs
to be extremely strict and i agree with
that i think that if you're if you're
building a competitive playlist you
should only be matching against people
who are you know gold two if you're in
gold two and that's a really strict
requirement but if you're in a free
freelance playlist there still needs to
be some protections it's like if you're
if you're dating right if you're a 10
you're you're not going to date anybody
near seven or lower you know and so you
shouldn't be doing pvp against them
i'm trying to say this in an
entertaining way if you're two then you
shouldn't you shouldn't uh you shouldn't
uh be in the same room as an eight niner
shot all of a sudden
this is the nicest possible way i could
put it is shadow you're a 10.
and so
uh you know you're either you're like
damn
you might want to take him out to dinner
first
you're either you're either gonna be
dating nine and you're gonna be feeling
uh pretty good about yourself or you're
gonna be dating a one and it feels like
charity uh but either way is a good
position for you because you're at the
the other end but what the problem with
your world view is it's completely
devoid of the other half of the equation
which by the way are most players and
it's not how you build an inclusive pvp
uh system it's not how you get more
people to play your game it's it's not
how you build a a pvp sandbox that if
you're if you're a one you should be
playing with fours and lower and that
that's you know you can say all you want
about player populations and wait times
and that sort of stuff but if you want
those problems to be solved you're not
going to do it by making playlists less
fun to be in harder to gain skills in uh
because the only people who get all the
advantages you're talking about of not
being sweaty and getting to experiment
are the people who are already good at
the game all right now you've spoken
shadow you're rebuttal
yeah so well some things first first of
all something i want to mention is you
mentioned like uh people in gold three
matching people in goal three i i just
want to say like that's completely
different from skill-based matchmaking
like i actually would love to see a
rank-based matchmaking where it's like
you rank up your points
if you can match people
in your rank you know that's fine you
know skill flies out the window at that
point i mean like you could be the best
player in the world and be in the lowest
rank just because you haven't played it
um but i mean you know after a few games
or after i don't know how many games it
would take but um i mean it's assumed
after a while that the best players are
the the best rank and the new newer
players or the worst players are at the
lower ranks i think that would be that
would be great um and i feel like
especially if they put actually
meaningful rewards behind that that
playlist it could be like super powerful
um
but for 6v6 i mean i i think that's the
6v6 is not competitive no matter how you
put it um and earlier you guys were
touching on the whole like uh
winning
decentvized thing
or like de-emphasized and honestly i'm i
think that is that is fine for 66
because even if you're even if you're a
10 even if you're the best player in the
world like it's gonna be difficult for
you to single-handedly win a 656 game
for your team like
there's 11 other people in the lobby
chances are you aren't going to be the
deciding factor of the game so i i don't
think that like people should be
sweating out like oh i gotta i got to
protect my win percentage in 6v6 i mean
especially if you're solo queueing
that's like completely useless so um
yeah i personally i don't care about
winning at all in 66 just because like
like i said i mean it's de-emphasized
from a loop perspective and i mean i i
can't if i would stress out so much if i
cared about winning in 66 could be like
oh my my teammates are throwing you know
yeah so
yeah nope m i want to jump in real quick
because you guys are making some good
points i definitely align with travis
on the
lower end and overall player population
right because the reality is they do
represent the majority of the people you
need for engagement right but my thing
is i want to ask you this shadow which
was i don't know if you missed it when
we came in and the statement they made
when they were saying how
because of this these type of
experiences whether it be because the
lower end is now either leaving the game
or whatever reason they're saying that
this is a not enjoyable experience for
this group of players and let's be
honest that's probably the majority of
the base that that is de-emphasizing
them
to
it emphasize rewards and to focus on
what i want to know like when you hear
bungie say a statement like that because
i don't know how you what you i don't
know how what side of the fence you are
i know i'm on the heavy
reward side and like i'm the guy that
like liked when recluse and mountaintop
was in in the mix right regardless to
they were you know maybe op later but at
least there was these
you know these goals to attain for what
you hit rank level so i wanted to know
like what did you feel when you read
that statement on bungie's thought
process
um
so are you talking about the part where
it says um
this has contributed us to us
de-emphasizing winning as a requirement
to gain rewards in the crucible yes yes
so i i think for 66 that makes total
sense because like i said i mean if
there's 11 other people in the lobby
like you you shouldn't have to stress
about your teammates and you know the
other all the other people in the lobby
for
um
for other modes like trials i mean i
think
winning still definitely does matter
flawless is still a thing so i don't i
don't think they've really de-emphasized
winning as a requirement for rewards you
like them glory
they have i mean you get you get rewards
on trials even if you don't win now and
i i think that's a good improvement by
the way but yeah
the game design of like they have a pvp
mode
where there's a winner and a loser and
the main reason you're in the match is
to win or lose and people don't actually
care about that and at that point what
like that's not really a pvp match i
mean that's yeah i think
i think there should definitely be modes
where winning matters a lot in terms of
rewards so yeah i agree and the thing i
would say about your 6v6 is you know
generally i agree it's a more casual it
is a more casual mode but in order for
those matches to feel good there still
it has to be some semblance of order uh
and the reason
you know you said earlier um if you're
playing with 11 other people you're not
going to be able to carry your entire
team and i think that that speaks to the
fact that destiny has bad matchmaking
because you should never be in that
situation where you feel like you have
to carry your entire team you should be
playing with five people on your team
who are similar in skill to you against
six people who are similar in skill to
you so that none of you feels like you
have to carry the team you all just play
your best and then hopefully the team
that works together the best or has the
better game will win uh and and i think
the fact that
there is such a
lack of like structure to their
matchmaking right now is the reason that
when you get to a match it feels like
the wild wild west and you feel like you
have to carry five other people um
that's an unfortunate side effect i
think of of the bad skill matchmaking
that they're doing right now that
skill-based matchmaking or at least some
structure to how they group people
together based on skill would be able to
fix i and you know i would just like to
see them try it i i'll say this for you
shadow which is that you're absolutely
right that this is the wrong playlist to
start this out on it's crazy that they
picked this and my guess is the reason
that they picked this is because it's
probably the one with the highest player
population and they want to actually do
like a real test on this thing so i get
the reasoning but it's odd when they see
uh the actual competitive game mode the
mode that's called comp languishing as a
playlist and having absolutely no hope
and then they're like well let's try
something that probably should be
applied somewhere else over
does competitive even exist anymore or
is it just called survival bro
for sure since trials came out that's
how i feel yeah it's like since trials
came back but i love i feel like
confidence and afterthought like cop is
and and that's where i've been
completely transferred i thought because
that's where i've been agreeing with i'm
like i thought that's the test bed we're
gonna do this with and let's get the
fours popping right let's see what's
going on there in the actual competitive
vote with skill base matchmaking plays
more of a factor so that's why i'm in
alignment with both of you there i
completely was surprised by that that
that glory is like like we're still not
talking about that yeah but no i think
we can all agree
with the attitude yeah i was gonna say i
think like literally everybody here all
four of us can say
glory comp survival whatever that thing
is right now needs a rework a ladder
would be amazing you know your bronze
silver gold platinum diamond you know if
you can get up to onyx put rewards
behind that structure as well that would
do a ton for one to incentivize the more
hardcore to go climb that ladder to give
the lower people a place to be around
their mindset
my question to you shadow now after
listening to everybody i think we all
agree comp needs a rework would be great
if it was would do a lot of things
probably to give people a reason to go
then you do have something like a rumble
or a control or a clash or scorch or
whatever
outside of trials
that is kind of your a little more in
between so my question to you is
do you have any like general things
against skill based matchmaking whether
it's like
like this would be like a bulleted list
like matchmaking time um can't test the
test off meta stuff are there things
like that that you would have opposition
to sbmm just kind of on a general level
yeah so um
i mean i think it's i think all the
things that bungie laid out in the twab
makes sense i mean there's there's
matchmaking times there's um you know
like they had they set up these
like all these different factors that
they're trying to prioritize when they
do the matchmaking there's connection
quality there's connection to the server
connection to the other players stuff
like that um
i think like
the fact that i sometimes like match
people from the other side of the planet
even when connection is at like the top
of the priority i think that's a little
screwed up like i i don't know i feel
like even right now where it's you know
supposedly purely connection based i'm
still matching people from the other
side of the planet in like the middle of
the day it's like i feel like
i feel like that's only gonna get worse
and i i have friends that are um
from areas of the world where destiny is
not as popular and they only match
people from the other side of the planet
and their connection is always awful and
i mean that that only gets worse with
skill-based matchmaking there's there's
no chance that that gets better in any
way um
so i i think connection is i mean a huge
thing um
another another thing and i think i
brought this up last time and travis
disagreed with me yes um
the whole the whole idea of uh
progression uh it gets gets really
screwed up with skill-based matchmaking
um
like when when i was a brand new player
in destiny 1 and i sucked i i still
didn't like the theory of skill-based
matchmaking because um no matter how get
how good you get people are just right
there with you like it isn't there isn't
like one of the main reasons to improve
so that you can start like playing
better against your opponents and if
your opponents are just going to
constantly get better with you it like
why would you improve like if your
chance of winning is going to be 50 50
if you're a complete noob and if your
chance of winning is going to be 50 50
if you're the best player in the world
like why would you ever want to become
the best player in the world if your
chances of success are always going to
be the same because the game just keeps
making your opponents more difficult and
more difficult more difficult okay so i
mean you're still getting better though
just to be clear
there's still value in you becoming a
better player it's not like if if it's
all about just oh if i'm better than i
should win more a higher percentage of
my matches you'll
you'll be able to do it in uh
in uh trials if it's card based you'll
be able to do it every season if you're
climbing a ranked ladder you'll be able
to do it if you do a private match
against your friends and you're just
kind of dabbing on them like it doesn't
exist in a vacuum where your win ratio
is the only sign that you're better or
worse i mean you
yeah i i could see why i disagree with
you last time this is making sense it
depends on it depends on the mode i mean
if you only play
the 6v6 control that has skill based
matchmaking you know like it really
depends i mean if you're a player who
plays every pvp mode then yeah i mean i
agree i mean there's there's modes where
getting better does
you know really matter but if if in a
world where there is strict skill-based
matchmaking i'm not saying that's what's
going to happen but in a world where
there's a strict skill-based matchmaking
um
i mean your your opponents will always
be as good as you so you know no matter
how good you get you're just you're
still going to have like a similar
experience um and at least in my view
the reason why a lot of people are
driven to improve in any game is so that
they can start like
seeing themselves get better relative to
their opponents like day one they go in
and they get stomped and they're like
dang this sucks you know day 30 they're
like okay you know i can i'm not doing
great but i'm at least surviving and
then day a thousand they're like wow i
can actually like
defeat the majority of people i come
across and like that's progression i
gotta push back shadow
you think the guy that got his soul
snatched
all
pumped into the ground spat on is coming
back after dave two or three like i mean
that's what i did bro
you're a different type of beast bro
like like listen i know dudes let's be
honest like
you know we gotta use the word the
casual audience they're gonna come in
and they wanna
have a somewhat positive experience
right however
right so they may not win but it's like
hey yo we got we almost had them that
one man we almost had them to kind of
incentivize to stick around
if you crush these guys
they are exiting stages they can play yo
bro i'm an apex maid now i'm i'm a
fortnight man i can't do this destiny
thing and i think that's where we gotta
have some empathy for those guys i say
that you don't i'm not saying that you
don't i'm just saying
i know i can relate as one of those
dudes at one point
like i was one of those dudes that's
what i'm trying to say i mean here's
what i'll tell you
good
the skill-based matchmaking is not the
biggest threat to you having a fun
experience where you play against
casuals and and win a lot of matches the
biggest threat to that is if all the
casuals that you would be able to fight
against leave and the only people
are cute
to make it anyway yeah you're going to
get there anyway
it's going to be it's going to be
highland highlander self-hatred based
matchmaking which like i want to point
out this that's not what you want this
this isn't a self this isn't a
self-interested or self-serving argument
i know
from my point of view and i believe i
think there are there are a lot of
players out there who you know they
don't create content they don't have any
social media like their only concern is
their own experience and i totally get
that point of view but i think um what a
lot of people don't realize who make
comments like oh content creators just
want to stomp noobs it's like a lot of
content creators have their livelihood
who's like directly related to the
health of the game and they genuinely
believe
i mean this is the case with me i
genuinely believe that uh skill-based
matchmaking in 656 is not for the better
health of the overall population the
overall game um so it's not like oh i
just want to stomp noobs or oh i think
this is going to make a better
experience for me myself no i mean
that's i mean sure that matters to me
but i think i'm way more concerned with
the overall health of the game
and i think that's a lot of content
creators have pointed that out like
their new their new philosophy is like
you know i don't i don't care about
myself i just want what's best for the
game because that honestly does
sometimes lead to a better experience
for themselves right you mentioned like
population numbers go up then the top
players have more people to defeat so i
mean you know go for you know however
however way you want to look
i feel your point can we be brutally
honest too
there is and i'm not saying this is you
at all we just have a fair honest
discussion there is a strong portion of
high-level content creators whose
content is based on hey i could get you
to the lighthouse
i can give you an easy run right because
i am so skilled that i could drag you
along and if this kind of happens it
goes against brand because now i they
may not that's maybe they still will but
some it'll be a harder time to go there
so i just wanted to be fair to both
sides on that side because it's like i
get it i just think that if we look at
it
objectively of what the base consists of
there's more casual players in that base
and to me
the health of a game
you need those guys to stick around if
we don't get 100 yeah yeah we don't get
those guys man
and
it it really it really takes
deteriorates the overall health so it's
going to be on them to figure this out
but i'm i'm with you shadow
on
sixes not necessarily
being the right test bed
to do it with i'm with you there you
know i'm saying i think that's why i
could be in the middle with you on that
part because i'm like the mode that
really needs it is comp fours you know
that kind of thing or if you're going to
play with trials stuff like that so it
was weird to me for them to do it like
that but look they got their work cut
out for them this is this is not going
to be easy we got obviously this
community is very vocal we all feel
strongly everybody's making
you know fantastic points you know it's
gonna it i don't envy them let's just
say like they're going to piss someone
off the key is to be with them it's the
last thing i'll give it to you e
is the data because we know bungie loves
that data they love their analytics see
these little nice charts you see you see
these graphs y'all you see these traps
little little colors and stuff like that
so that's gonna be the ultimate say and
it's going to be interesting
once they implement what actually
happens with those engagements i'm very
curious and that's where we can all
agree disagree because they try to come
back and say hey look look at them
engagement doubles y'all want it
right we go we're going to see how much
they play out so i'm very curious
as well yeah yeah i was like i mean all
of you guys have some pretty interesting
points
for me city like you see if you go like
the bell curve i think that's kind of
one of the interesting charts to look at
he's got the bell curve and where the
population the median of that population
sits they said right at about a hundred
for their skill level chart negative
thousand to a thousand
so i guess my question for you shadow
as an experiment
now granted i don't want to see you guys
get 10-minute matchmates that's stupid
but i feel like bungie has this
idea in their mind if it's not a
60-minute matchmaking thing it's like
they've failed but if they went up to
like 90 seconds for generally more
matches
but i feel like there there's got to be
a little give and take and they said
that some of the matchmaking times are
going to be longer no do i think anyone
should have to wait 10 minutes to get a
match because they're trying to match
with somebody in like
you know japan's trying to match with
south america which is trying to match
with new york and it's like in
everybody's laggy i get that point and
again that's where the latter is like
you're going to be in your ladder that's
going to be your tight very strict
matchmaking but to a point when you look
at this skill graph if i look at
somebody who's like negative 800
and then you look at somebody on the
other side who's like an 800 skill
in my head
if those two are ever on
opposing teams that feels like
the 800 has a really crappy day and the
eight or the negative 800 has a really
crappy day and then the 800 has
you know an easy target basically in my
head now this is just the example
as the population is 50 is 100 and above
even if you just for their loose sbm for
say control or as travis is saying
general modes need to have still some
and this is kind of where i was saying
the outlier protection that's why i was
asking you
i was like
i guess for me is like if you take you
where do you find the benefit for
you know somebody who's at a negative
600
matching into a match for you not from
your side but do you feel like a
negative 600 gets anything out of
matching into a match with
you or anybody at 800 900 a thousand do
they get anything out of that match or
is there a point where
if you have 1 000 to
negative 200 of the pool to work with
which is most of them the people who are
below that probably could work from 600
up to maybe like 400 but you're just
outside of that window most the
population like 70 75 of populations in
that group
but there are some that wouldn't be does
that make sense
yeah
so what's the question do you have a
question no the question like kind of
going back do you because you were
saying you don't want sbm in control of
like do you from like the 800 like the
negative 800 is do they get anything out
of being in a match with an 800 like
somebody who's 1600 points apart from
them on this little bell curve is there
a benefit for them being in the match
against somebody who's that far ahead
i i don't know about you know i it
really depends where you draw the line i
think there's certainly a benefit to
playing against people who are like
notably better than you i think that's
the fastest way to improve um anyone who
is who has ever been in the competitive
scene in any game will tell you like the
fastest way to improve is play against
people who are better than you play with
people who are better than you learn
from what they do right and also you you
become a much smarter player because if
you're playing against people who are
better than you uh you won't get away
with a bunch of bad habits and mistakes
um if if you're playing people like
exclusively at your skill level and you
happen to be at 0.2 kd or something you
get away with basically everything and
you won't really learn like what what
what it takes to like make a good play
um so i think there's definitely a
benefit to i mean in terms of skill
progression alone i think there's
definitely a benefit to playing against
people who are significantly better than
you but if you want to match a guy who's
on like i said day one of the game
versus someone who's been playing for
years that you know obviously they're
going to get stomped and they probably
won't learn very much uh you know if
they're getting absolutely annihilated
they have literally like one or two
kills you know um but i think you know
to a certain extent playing people then
better you is like an okay thing and i
was like i agree yeah i i get that too
as you said to an extent and i think
that's kind of where
hopefully their loose matchmaking kind
of does get like the new player away
from the
you know
trials carry godstream or like those you
know the the outliers the there should
be a pretty decently wide range so that
way it's like hey i want a gunfight but
also man that guy was like vertical i
need to figure out how to jump more and
part of it is on the player mindset too
like you go look up any person
you can walk into a pvp match and be
like oh no i didn't shoot my gun right
it's like okay well you gotta practice a
little bit but there's also a point
where if i do want to practice there is
there's probably a level like i
shouldn't go shoot hoops against lebron
he's going to stuff every shot
exactly
but better just keep no no no i'm never
going to get better against lebron every
shot is gonna get 100 out of 100 get
stuff against that man
you you you get better by playing
against players that are uh somewhat
better than you that are reasonably
better than you within a certain degree
because like you know
you know i'll get better if i go up
against another boxer in the
featherweight division but you know i
don't want to be that that dude that
dude that got
i don't want to be that dude they got
beat on by mike tyson on the airplane
you know what i mean like that guy
didn't learn anything that day about
boxing he wasn't taking
tips from that he's just getting his ass
whooped so i just think you know that's
why you want protections this is this is
like good game design so uh i you know i
i generally agree like you should there
should always be people
in your playlist that are
above you and people that are below you
well unless you're the worst player or
the best player then that that's always
going to be true but uh you know you
want to put in some guard rails
otherwise people atrophy they get they
throw off the game they you know they
and you don't want that it it's
self-destructive to the own thing that
you're trying to build um and i think i
think bungie has sort of let it go for a
long period of time and it's great that
they're finally talking about it if they
want to get serious about pvp again it
needs to be a discussion on the table
because
the server populations aren't there to
support really anything that they want
to do right now so why would they invest
time in it
they need to fix the real problem yeah
and i think the the right approach is
getting the look pvp got a ton of issues
we ain't got no damn maps we barely got
a riff mode we we just getting little
little you know little scraps on the
kitchen table down and we get a little
excited so the the thing first is the
core the core base this this type of
discussion that we're having right and
like getting that right getting the
matchmaking right in the line and then
the proper love with the modes the maps
the actual
rewards and then we kind of get back to
where we need to be because at the end
of the day i always and we've said it
for the longest i think we're all in
agreement here
that when destiny pvp is good
it can carry it during these lulls
during the low of the solstice we've
done all the story [ __ ] if pvp was
popping right now and people are really
engaged well i think we all agree it's
better for the health of the game so the
good thing is they're finally starting
to talk about this side of the house
seriously we all have our thoughts you
know what i'm saying but at the end of
the day i think overall still the right
direction right it's still hey this
thing needs love we understand it let's
implement it and let's see how it goes
and hopefully they take the feedback and
we get to where we need to be
yeah i was like i mean
we all want ranked we all would love
some maps
um i mean you know a little variety goes
a long way too is like if you're not
seeing the same three maps in a cycle of
iron banner for
a week straight when you're trying to
grind out a title then that gives you a
little more stuff
yeah so it's like those are those are
moments where
the issues and it's like and i don't
want any high or low skilled player to
be like trying to find that like that
group of people that's somewhat near
them that takes like a 10-minute match i
don't want that that's what i was like i
actually think
they're kind of dancing a reasonable
line with this loose
matchmaking if you get a scale of one to
ten and you go like three to ten and one
to seven and you're like you know
cutting out the ends i feel like it's
going to be reasonable is it is it going
to be the magic for everybody no but
hopefully shadow doesn't have a 10
minute match make maybe his is two
minutes instead of one but
also on the other side
if the population grows
by people having slightly more mat like
better matches
then in general then your population
time
maybe over the course of time could
actually get shorter if the population
grows because more people are having a
better time in there but this is
something as we've all probably talked
about since it was three years without
anything
that this needs consistency for people
to actually stick with the moon
some rewards obviously a good thing the
ranking we've talked about would be
wonderful but if more people stay in the
mode and grow these playlists just in
general overall
then your two-minute matchmaking now
comes down to 90 seconds
and yet more people are having a better
experience in general matches and more
people can hopefully start climbing up
into your skill pool too
i don't know
for me i feel like this is like an
experiment but hopefully won't piss too
many people off as long as they have
like all the dials and sliders correct
because if it's one of those things
where they think it's right and then it
launches and it's completely horrible
it's one of those things i think could
be actually worse so hopefully like the
testing the dials and you know the the
matchmaking algorithm is doing what they
want it to do because if it comes in all
of a sudden like i'm fighting no i have
like a lobby of like shadows and cool
guys and then there's like my team for
some reason has like me and
all the people worse than me i'm like
and that's just like all i'm getting
then some people are gonna be really
confused if it doesn't do anything
completely broken like that i think it
is a step in
a reasonable direction that hopefully is
a balance because i understand shadow's
points of view it's like sometimes you
want to go in experiment or
you know to a point but i also feel like
on you know travis and cogg's side as
well the casual the general population
we want to build that up and as a lot of
people have said
it's to a point where
whatever helps that population number
grow i know a lot of people just kind of
come to hopefully accepting whatever
that is
yeah
the fun that is bungee and the pvp said
box yeah um can i just say their um
their change of matching teams against
teams
that's one of like the best like
matchmaking changes they've ever done in
my opinion shadow we're here bro i i
said the fact that they even
acknowledged that and a bullet point was
huge to me
yeah yeah fire team size for what season
19 is where we're looking at so that
will be a little that's a bit far out
yeah i was like yeah people have been
asking for this forever so i'm glad it's
it's a thing i guess
part of me is like how is that not
already a thing because you could take
using my random number
you know algorithm if you can't take a
team of sixes
you would probably match those up
against like a bunch of you know randoms
or twos or so lows of like sevens or
like they need to be matched to somebody
above because of what that team
coordination can do
like and again is it gonna be that tight
no but it's like the team's
general skill versus like the solos
somewhere that team needs like a team
advantage bump because you're i mean
there's six people sitting in a discord
yeah they've got an advantage over
people
even at their skill level playing solo
so it's like the fact that it's
acknowledged is huge and
it's kind of one of those i'm just still
surprised is apparently taking a little
while to get noticed because i don't
know why for some reason you'll go into
a lobby you're like why does it feel
like all six solos are going against
teams of six
it feels like that sometimes because all
of a sudden you just seem to be i'm by
myself i'm with a whole bunch of random
people i don't know and those people all
seem to be talking to each other the
entire time
i was like so
no the fact that you mentioned the fire
team size i think that's another piece
too that will hopefully help that as
well because they mentioned uh you know
teams making a massive difference when
it comes to you know skill under the
bell curve but no the fire team size
would be huge
and that hopefully if that can take away
the need for freelance
in say like trials
theoretically if like if it's very
weighted for solos to be solos but every
so often
i'm fighting okay finally i felt a two a
two team versus you know one and three
okay that's okay every so often but like
if i generally see
most people who are like me and then the
threes generally see more of the threes
that's fair on both ends of the equation
i feel
yeah definitely
yeah i think that that could have that
could be the solution right because they
split the pool like a trillion ways with
freelance sometimes so i feel like that
could be a solution to not exactly split
the pool but
make it so that everyone's still coming
into the same thing and everyone's
hopefully having a pretty decent
experience
yeah or they can stop making separate
playlists for each game mode and just
throw a bunch of them into
there should be two playlists party
lists little halo yeah there should be a
casual playlist where it just mixes and
matches all the different game modes and
then a competitive one that's like
uh oh yeah
player operation populations that's easy
way to do it control
flash
rumble i think should be in there too
just to make people occasionally play
solo like all of those random playlists
that are you know under this current
connection based thing put those all in
one and then queue up and be like okay
i'm by myself i got to pay attention and
like let everybody know and then okay
now it's clash just kills and tell
people or zone control and then it's
pure objective and have people rotate
through those but again it's just one
big group of people getting dumped into
the same pool
you know behind
if you had this boat that they created
called fiesta and it's like a gun game
oh dude i still want an exotic i want an
exotic gun game in this are you kidding
me
the mode that they created themselves
back in the day and like just go bring
that over here because you got like some
of the best exotics going and weapon
design and like that how cool would that
be right you start off and everybody get
a rat kick you know saying everybody
like let's go you know say like you can
do so much it would be allowed to
experiment with stuff like that if they
would consolidate some of their
playlists because that's the problem is
you go and you do something you make
like a scorch game and you either have
to look like you know rotate it out once
a month or
you uh make it its own playlist and then
you know nobody clicks on that little
button or nobody even knows that little
button exists how many they use yeah
they use like scorch and mayhem because
they're fast and then they just afk
also you know what there shouldn't even
be a freelance button on any of these
playlists if you click on you know a a
crucible playlist and you're not in a
party with any other people it should
automatically know that and it should
match you with other freelance players
why is there a separate note i have so
many problems with uh bungie's uh
multiplayer design right now the sandbox
just makes it
well the only problem with that is that
if you have a team of two in trials like
obviously a solo player has to fill that
third spot so you have to still have at
least some of them coming in i mean same
with a team of five and
like whatever buttons for it you know
what i mean they could just decide they
could organically identify and and match
people
yeah i guess
yeah it's just it's crazy to me because
then they leave it up to players making
mistakes because players don't know
about someone accidentally queueing into
this into the t1 yeah
i do that all the time i was like there
are there's people in my chat that i've
said you know there's a freelance button
and they're like no
yeah that's that's the thing i've seen
yeah yeah
i did want to ask you um shadow the
trials map
we had rusted lands widows court and
eternity what did you vote for
i didn't actually vote but i would
probably vote for widows court
you like sniping that's not surprising
honestly though i i'm not a huge fan of
any of them and i haven't i haven't
played trials a whole lot this season i
i don't i don't know if i'm going to be
playing it this week so i i'm not super
concerned i was very surprised eternity
won i guess i don't know maybe chat let
me know but i was just surprised to see
e turn because i voted widow's court if
you like sniping cool i get that and
that was 31 rusted lance i feel like has
kind of lanes for all the options
i was just surprised eternity i don't
ever picture this as being the map that
people
really want to play
but yeah i was surprised maybe just
because it's relatively new people are
like we've played widows court and we've
played rusted landscapes last five
million years
so i mean even though it's not a new map
it's still you know one
kind of new fake new yeah
the least played in recent history so i
guess people i mean i can understand
people saying like you know i want to
mix it up a little bit
yeah that's what i did i voted for
eternity just because i feel like i've
played the other maps way too much
that's i'm saying that in chat actually
that makes that's that seems to be a
thing okay a couple of hot questions uh
shadow and then i don't know what your
time is like and then i can let you go
uh which raid on august 23rd which raid
do you want to see come back
oh
i don't know okay first of all do you
guys think that there's any chance at
all of them bringing back a d2 raid
you know the way they phrased it
what a curveball that would be no
they've they've literally phrased that
they said uh will be our second at
bringing a raid out of the destiny
content vault they didn't say d1 now
granted i feel like they said d1 like a
year ago yeah but like it would
definitely be like and we're bringing
back
all what if they okay here's the only
one that might actually work no all of
the leviathan raids
are gonna say what if they did all of
the leviathan raids and what they did
leviathan
and then all apartment 2b and 2c
we got my man scarole in here and if i
see that damn spire stars yeah it's a d1
raid that's what i thought friday y'all
get ready let's go
what i mean like they did half of the
work for the leviathan
it's partially there
i know where you're going no they people
would lose their mind
[Laughter]
i do love the question though i think
you i think that's one of those like
moments where bungie's like let's see if
we can get our community's head to
explode
yes
but it could explode right
imagine they're listening right now and
they're like oh gosh this is a mistake
um
you get four raids if you brought back
the whole leviathan though i mean
hold on i gotta get sparrow he said he
rather aspired that kingsville we we
gotta we gotta do something about this
of course rather spider than king's
false but aspires his favorite raid this
is un
sorry i'm sorry i'm not favorite strike
but yeah this is favorite um
anyway so to answer your original
question from 10 years ago i i'd
probably pick king's fall um just from a
personal perspective i barely played
that raid in d1 um and i think it was
one that i mean even though i played it
like
probably only a couple of times i really
enjoyed it so i would love to see that
come back
nice
uh
do you where do you feel on the friday
raid launch date three days after
um i mean i i've never really been a
day one raider so i'm like personally
not super concerned about it but for the
overall community i mean i think
generally people you know have their
whole uh you know week weekends off and
you know it works better for people who
are in school and blah blah
bungie or i think uh lyanna said that it
was like a a thing where they wanted to
have people on their work days at bungie
so that if anything goes wrong they can
address it really fast and i mean i i
think that makes sense and that's fair
as well so
uh and then finally if we
uh how many maps do you think we are
going to get next season for pvp
uh
none i don't know
i i really don't know um have they have
they said anything about like plans for
maps per season or anything no i was
just curious because they've been pretty
good about it i was just curious if i
think if you had a number in mind if
it's zero at zero yeah i i well wait
they're they're bringing i think they
said they were going to bring back maps
but not make a new one
if if i remember correctly um so yeah in
that case if we get like one or two old
maps sounds good i highly doubt there'll
be another brand new one
yeah i think what was it because we were
supposed to get
one
new one which we got the one with rift
this season we were gonna get like two
reprised ones and then one from destiny
some order of something like that i
remember so there might be one reprised
or something coming back next season
um and then what what makes you the most
excited about arc 3.0 and then we'll
wrap it up
um um
i i think they kind of alluded to it
kind of having some movement things in
it and i think that could be really cool
i mean whether that's blink or some new
movement ability or i i don't know the
potential is endless there could be
there could be some really cool movement
things um
but i'm also just i'm also just excited
to see the the general quality of life
updates for the
for the whole arc thing with you know
grenades being universal and you know
just just having more uh ability to
build craft so
yeah i'm i'm just i'm just looking
forward to it overall and seeing how it
pans out the sandbox
nice
uh that was kind of my quick fire you
guys got anything else for him before we
wrap this thing up because we managed to
steal a guest for an hour
that was awesome
pulling up man some good fun debate oh
yeah i i'm gonna agree i think
it's gotta be king's form man i gotta
hear sabothune's voice that's the the
taking the king will return
i'll be like remember what's happened
through and said the two lies are two
truths oh yeah yeah yeah so i i i gotta
i gotta see that like i got to see her
get her her truth off you know say look
everybody all my hardcore guys y'all
know i'm a vogue i know if i get to
slander but i do respect pigs four
it's time it's time shout out to job
he's out here putting up clips of d1
i've got to get in the field like yeah
i'm ready to shoot all the earrings now
let's go and i want to see
yeah i want to see the changes i want to
see
what's the subtle change now don't get
me wrong if it's not king's fall it is
wrath i'm not gonna be mad but if it's
not king's fault or wrath
yeah if they do if they do a crota if
they do a d2 raid
i i want to just like sit back with like
the stephen colbert popcorn emoji and 3d
glasses as the world explodes man
bro
like i will see any of them apartment 2
b2c leviathan joints i don't want to see
crown and i want him well it ties to the
story the next
i don't want to see you right now bro
that's just hey scarole would be pumped
dude if we got back all of leviath and
scarah would be like sweet my favorite
raid's back and everybody got like three
can you imagine if that was the day one
raid challenge you had to do the normal
race
and then you had to do the other three
as well
oh my god
put them all into one raid
yeah you have to go straight from one to
another
down to the trash compactor the spyro
stores to
yeah as someone who came from world of
warcraft where raids are long or at
least some of them are long i would love
to see a long destiny raid dude like
i don't know yeah when i first came to
destiny i was like wait that's it
there's only like a few bosses and like
some like jumping puzzle you know like
in wow some braids have like 15 bosses
you know that would be sick i mean even
though you know it would take long i
think i think it also added a culture of
like it's fine to go into a raid and
only clear a few bosses you don't have
to go through the entire thing you know
because i mean different bosses give
different loot so anyway if there's if
they want to make a long ride personally
i'd i think that'd be super cool
scarole's got the idea of king's fall
combined with crota
oh
start with crota's people would be like
you start with the crota strike and then
you go through like the portal and then
you go into king's fall
that that i would be on board with that
that'd be actually kind of a cool twist
i don't imagine they don't tell you and
you just load it on day one everyone's
pissed
oh no that'd be a yeah like i'd love
they don't tell you like what it is
until the node goes live and everybody's
like where's the node where's the node
then all of a sudden somebody finds it
on the moon and it says crota's in
they're like no and then you finish you
beat crota and then it's like it sucks
you into king's fall and they're like
like that would be one of the cool
moments that unfortunately
yeah i was like i never expected to
happen that'd be freaking awesome so
from d1 but i will be sad if we don't
get wrath because i love cj but
things fall actually has nothing to do
with the encounters it's because i'm
hoping that they use this opportunity to
not necessarily tell stories because i
know they don't want to tell new stories
of the raid but just uh thematically
match up what's happening in destiny
with some of the old stuff because i
think the fact that king's fault isn't
playable in d2 is a detriment to people
who are trying to understand the story
that they're currently telling in which
queen and so that's why i'm going to
choose that one i just want
you know they talk about orcs so much
and the fact that you can't do the raid
where you fight orcs is kind of silly to
me so
yeah i would just like them to put it in
there makes destiny 2 a bit more a bit
more completive and they're still
missing like the red war and forsaken
but you know to
eat them as we go all right uh chat you
guys have been fantastic thank you guys
for being here so many of you some
awesome super chats um you guys have
been great if you are still hanging out
definitely make sure you guys hit the
like button button
um
shadow like bucket like bucket yeah it
needs to be a bucket because there's so
many likes no i'm kidding you fit the
likes in there i add your like to the
bucket everybody and you're like
if you shoot from behind the line it's
three points you know you gotta go for
the extra
um no but shadow thank you for uh
dropping into the call um i was honestly
like didn't quite have a gut one fell
through and i was like wondering who i
could ask and i did not imagine your
schedule is gonna allow it so
very happy to see you in chat and very
happy to have you in here so for those
people who may have heard the last show
or not but definitely for reprieve where
do people find all of your amazing
wonderful content
and you first of all just want to say
thank thanks for having me on um you can
find me on youtube at shadow destiny
short and sweet very fun
lovely love discussion like that
it really and i i think i think people
are listening to us i don't care what
nobody's i i'm gonna die on this hill
but you be paying attention to put all
pvp discussions on because this was
something we've been asking for a 12
like this for the longest for the pvp
community so i think it's a great start
if we get a ladder ranked playlist then
we'll
we'll know we we were we were at least
in the ear that voted for that somewhere
i told you i know bungie listens to the
show sometimes they message me after the
show to say
i tell you that one of the ones that
they messaged me about was when i said
that i made the segregation joke about
yo
the small one using different bathrooms
and then somebody from bungie hit me up
and was like dude
what are you doing
i i think i do remember that and i was
like oh of all the things that they hear
you're segregating fallen into the
swallowing bathrooms i was i died
yeah some of the best content is we we
do those tower narratives about what
happened during the lakshmi era those
would be the fun show oh man yeah that's
good
uh travis what are you working on what's
the next thing they can look for from
you yeah yeah um you can read my review
of xenoblade chronicles 3 on ign you can
read my preview of roller drum on ign
and then next up i'm doing a preview of
construction simulator and a review that
i can't talk about yet but i'll probably
be able to talk about it tomorrow um and
then uh yeah uh other than that follow
me on twitter at ty guy travis watch the
show watch my sunday show bitcast and uh
thanks for listening to my aggressive
takes on crucible everyone
i love having you on your shadow it's
always great to hear your perspective
thanks dude
you already know me at lordcognito on
twitter catch along podcast every
sundays the lord's day should have some
fun guests probably gonna be talking
about the esports community and some
just to see the rise of it and we're
gonna have some like uh
corporate lawyers and things in that
space trying to show why it's a growing
community so check that out justin
jacobson should be principal so
hopefully we should go catch that learn
a lot about what's going on in the scene
as far as i'm defining duke please
support mr maddie plays is back his back
is doing better we just finished
recording a good duke so go check that
out and then oh supports of ultimate
size solve on we're talking about life
kind of like after the activision
blizzard potential acquisition what are
some other potential targets things of
that nature and um yeah man lords of
gaming.net all the people in the show
everybody declared everybody to chat
today
real cool to see you know the discussion
everybody having fun and of course
shadow pulling up but uh what you got
going on man i just want to see the
giant distinction between shadows outro
and cogs outro
shadows like me be like yeah i bought
this everywhere and cog's got like cog
knows too many people and things and
he's in so many he's got so much to
shout out i just like we got a pencil in
a couple and the travis is like review
uh ibontis like twitch twitter youtube
cool shadow like yes and then cog is
over here like hold on i gotta shout out
17 homies uh
we have to give them the oscar or the
oscar music yeah
be like we got to start playing the
music for him
all right i'd like to thank my mom and
uh
uh no we love you it just cracks me up
because yeah some of us are
but that's part of the reason why we why
we all love you is because you do shout
out and support everybody that's near
you and you don't
you try not to forget anyone it's it's
really always quite impressive so uh for
me yeah youtube twitch twitter i will
try to get back on twitch a little more
it's been off streaming because of lots
of things and i got injured so we're
finally getting back to being reasonable
there but
uh shadow our pleasure to have you on
perfect chat to have somebody on and
honestly you're the exact person i
wanted on to have the you know balance
to our equation so thank you so much for
having us um
i saw the skill base matchmaking and i
was like oh
i know they're gonna be talking about it
he's like i have an opinion hello
that's what's great about debate having
the balance having that other side you
know good stuff 100
all right for episode number 208 with
the guest amazing appearance by shadow
that's all we got for the night so thank
you very much it has been